EU ministers in charge of energy policy
looked into the reasons behind the high
energy bills in Europe and their impact
on consumers in Europe electricity
prices for industries are twice as high
those in the US and twenty percent
higher than in China and if we talk gas
prices can be three to four times higher
than comparable US and Russian tariffs
for the council one of the problems is
that very often the final price paid by
the consumer does not only reflect the
price of energy but it is beefed up by
other costs and taxes we at the council
think that it is necessary to have to
have a more detailed examination and a
more detailed approach of the costs
arising from the network's themselves
ministers concluded that reducing energy
prices is necessary to foster
competitiveness and protect consumers
and emphasize the importance of energy
efficiency and energy saving measures
ministers reaffirmed also the need to
conclude an internal energy market
within 2014 as their environment
counterparts on Monday energy ministers
debated also on the new framework for
climate and energy policy for 2030 and
agreed that the e use green goals need
to go hand-in-hand with a more
competitive European industry